this is what's fun about playing
characters you get to dress up as an
individual and do some odd things there
are always mishaps and malfunctions
behind the scenes in hollywood chris
hemsworth's experience is no different
we'll be going into his hilarious
awkward nude scenes throwing it back to
his very first time on camera and
recounting his several onset accidents
what about chris hemsworth and thor
number one things get a bit cheeky in
this already iconic thor love and
thunder scene and flick
you flick too hard damn it on the day of
filming about 350 fox studio employees
decided to visit the set everyone from
the offices had never
ever dared to visit set
there in an interview with
australiasnews.com
chris goes into detail about how russell
crowe made him feel more comfortable
during the scene he does a great thing
where he's also naked from the waist
down that made me feel at ease we also
can't leave out taika ytt's commitment
on set it's an agreement we have i was
naked too
number two this is giving a whole new
meaning to dancing queen chris hemsworth
knows how to give the fans what they
want this time it's an entire dance
sequence to abba it's a dance scene it's
a full
dance-off shooting lightning at his
fingertips and so on we're counting the
days until this gets released to the
public
number three we're tripping hard over
this one in his new netflix film spider
head chris plays the more serious role
of a director utilizing convicts for
emotion altering experiments though the
role itself was pretty straightforward
there was one scene in particular where
his character is affected by the darken
flocks drug that he found pretty scary
to portray in an interview with
cinemablend he gives us some insight
into what it was like that was intense i
had to i don't know in the space of a
minute go through about four or five
different emotions and it was a thing
that scared me reading the script i
thought this is going to be either
really cool or really hokey and i'm
thankful it worked out number four it's
hammer time one thing we learned about
thor ragnarok is the fight scene between
thor and hulk is blended together with
cgi chris is in a completely different
room than mark ruffalo who plays the
hulk they hardly ever see each other
while filming his part of the fight
chris unfortunately had a bit of a
hammer mishap i think i probably did
more damage to myself just kind of
swinging the big thing around and
catching my head in the middle of it
number five chris really shows his range
in this one in the movie bad times at
the el royale he gets to play the
complex character of billy lee because
of his relationship with the writer and
director drew goddard chris said yes to
the role before reading the script
though he was a big fan of the script
itself he found the character of billy
lee to be quite awful we were kind of
laughing in between takes gun this guy
is a narcissistic creep at the end of
each day chris had to make sure he shook
off all of billy's energy he didn't want
to carry it around with him he was also
pretty grateful his wife was in
australia while he was shooting in
vancouver so she didn't have to look at
me too often which is probably a good
thing
number six chris hemsworth on a horse
say less we're throwing it back to his
first project the saddle club it was a
children's show about kids who ride
horses he was around 18 at the time and
came onto the show to play a vet it was
his first time ever speaking on camera i
was so terrified and you can see you can
hear my voice it's kind of way up here
everything's tense and i'm i'm floss red
he was so mortified over his performance
he went home and told his mom that's it
my career's over number seven not like
anyone's really complaining now we know
for sure chris doesn't have a problem
taking his shirt off but something he
does have a problem with is being too
predictable when the first thor movie
came out he was more than happy to
accommodate but when it was time to
shoot the third movie he fought pretty
hard for his modesty in an interview
with cinemablend he goes into detail
about his conversation with tyka about
it taika said no i think we need a shirt
off scene i was like ugh no we've done
that don't make me do it again i just
think it has to be different each time
number eight also known as comedy gold
we have yet another moment where chris
gets to strip down in front of a crew
full of people but in this comedic
direction he's packing a little extra
down below we're of course talking about
his 2015 film vacation he totally just
came in here to show off his six-pack
the writers and directors john francis
daly and jonathan m goldstein took chris
into a room and had him try on several
fake male appendages before they landed
on the perfect one for the scene it may
not seem like it during the movie but
chris was super embarrassed the entire
time
number nine more like cape malfunction
one of chris hemsworth's most
embarrassing moments is when he's doing
a heroic entrance or fight scene and the
cape just flies over his head making him
look less heroic and more comedic we've
had to kind of cut the cape down a
little bit and have shorter versions
that we then
digitally have to replace later number
10. more than one actually there's a
scene in the avengers where thor takes
loki off a ship and lands gracefully
onto a cliff yeah behind the scenes
chris had a much harder time sticking
that landing in an interview with
collider he doesn't spare any details on
this hilarious mishap so i was on a wire
because i hadn't learned to fly yet and
i had to come down and land on the cliff
step and have the conversation for the
first couple of takes and it's going to
turn up on the dvd extras somewhere i
just face planted into the dirt
number 11. we've got another nude scene
for you chris hemsworth has truly had a
lot of practice stripping down in front
of the camera but you'd be surprised to
find out he still gets pretty nervous
when doing so when he read the script
for rush for the first time he was a bit
taken aback by the nude scene that was
in the first 10 minutes of the film in
an interview with e news he talks a
little bit about what it felt like to
shoot i've been training a lot anyway
but it's still pretty awkward it's more
intimidating than the driving scenes a
hundred people standing around the
cameras and quick get your gear off
number 12. who wouldn't want to play
james hunt though of course chris wasn't
embarrassed to play him he was just
super nervous about it he has so much
respect for the actual james hunt that
he describes himself as feeling
nerve-wracked and afraid when prepping
for the role i just kind of
allowed that fear um to to motivate me
into my prep number 13 chris hemsworth
on line one when writer director paul
feig saw chris perform on saturday night
live he thought he would be perfect for
the ghostbusters team chris obviously
accepted but i read the script and i
said there's still nothing in here like
what am i what am i doing chris
definitely wasn't as comfortable with
improv as he is now my immediate
reaction was i
this is not on the end of my career but
i'm going to ruin this film number 14.
this time it wasn't with thor's hammer
in the movie extraction chris hemsworth
plays a black market mercenary who is
sent on a dangerous rescue mission
obviously there are going to be a ton of
intense fight scenes chris and his
co-star ron deep huda had to fight each
other for three weeks straight we both
had our fair share of cuts and bruises
and actually a couple of times i nicked
him but it was by accident and i felt
very embarrassed number 15 speak for
yourself chris something you may not be
aware of is that he was actually pretty
disappointed in himself with his
portrayal of thor in the second film i
was a little disappointed in what i'd
done i didn't think i drew the character
in any way i didn't think i showed an
audience something unexpected and
different he really didn't want to
continue in the same way he described
himself as feeling bored and wanting to
break the mold of the character
even with all of his embarrassing
moments chris hemsworth is still the
hilarious hard-working heartthrob we
know him to be which one of his movies
is your favorite